وزير الدفاع التركي خلوصي اكار انا بلاده
لن تسمح بوجود من وصفهم بالارهابيين في
المنطقه القريبه منها وقال اكار خلال
فعاليه لحزب العداله والتنميه الشماليه
البلاد ان عمليات بلاده العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه هدفها الوحيد هو مكافحه الارهاب
على حد تعبيره كما اشار المسؤول التركي
الى انقره ابلاغت اجتماع موسكو الثلاثي
بانها لا يمكنها تحمل موجه جديده من
اللاجئين السوري
فندق فندق
في مكافحه الارهاب وانه ليس لدينا هدف غير
مكافحه الارهاب كما هو معلوم يوجد في
بلدنا ما يقارب 4 ملايين لاجئ سوري ووفقا
للشروط الحاليه في بلدنا وبنيتها فاننا لا
يمكننا تحمل لاجئين جدد وانه لا يمكننا
القبول بموجه لجوء جديده لذلك فان ما نقوم
به من فعاليات هدفوا هذا مانو بقايا
شقائنا السوريين في مناطقهم